so for instance let's have a think about
this y equals x squared business right
to get an inverse out of it instead of
just saying y equals x squared I'm going
to restrict to this patch over here
right I'm gonna make it domain X is well
how I say this is an inequality what
part of the graph of I got what values
of x greater than do you reckon I can
include 0 I think including zeros okay
right because remember what I don't want
to have is any double ups right but at x
equals 0 you don't have a double up it's
just right there at one spot right so if
I take this then the inverse will become
y equals well you only get the top part
you see that you don't you have to
disregard the negative bit right so you
get this guy now the domain X is greater
than equals 0 remember when we went from
a function to its inverse we swapped
everything right we soft every X becomes
a y every Y becomes an X well when you
swap this you get a y is greater than or
equal to remain anymore at all what is
that that's that's range right so this
is actually really important the domain
of your original becomes the range of
your inverse and the if we cared about
it the range of your original becomes
the domain of your mouse that's actually
worth writing down when we swap X's and
Y's we swap range and domain as well
okay now just a really small sub note
right you notice over here I was like I
just chose apart we just chose this part
over here right whatever you would like
to suggest to me
why didn't we you know how to draw this
Bowman why didn't we pick the other part
like this part over here there's another
restriction what's the domain of this
graph over here X is the less than or
equal zero right now you can take that
and just like before you can put on y
equals x and you can reflect it across
you will get this shape over here that
that's sort of too far sorry there we go
so you're still going to get like is
that is that an inverse function the
blue graph comes up right so why don't
we do that why do you think we will do
this rather than this main you take is
when did you first start using square
roots what topic was it in do you
remember hmm way before I indices it was
actually Pythagoras right because you'd
say oh if you know what this side is and
you know what this side is then you'd
say this is the square root of this Plus
this so you like or any way I need to
know what square roots are right but in
the context of measuring triangles the
only thing that makes sense is a
positive value you want to get things
above the axis those are positive values
you're like well these are I mean I
could take them but what's the point
okay now the real issue is uh if I put
the rest of the graph back on the real
issue is that guy there see how it turns
around that's the issue right the two
graphs are we started with three X minus
one I think and what was X cubed plus
two the reason I gave you these two is
because neither of them turns did you
notice that you can go back to where you
drew these on your page you're like
there's no turning point and so these
are both think back to when we were
classifying functions do you remember
when we did that one mini business all
that kind of thing right what kinds of
functions are these think about them
these are both one-to-one that's why I
deliberately games you interesting to
you right but this guy over here
the original y equals x squared is not
one-to-one is it which one is it
it's many to one many different X values
will give you the same Y value right so
the problem with having a many to one is
that when you swap everything around
you're swapping the many and the one you
get a one to many this guy which is not
a function anymore right so that's why
we have to learn to restrict the domain
now if for example I'm not even going to
worry about the numbers I'm just going
to draw a picture for you right
if for example I gave you a graph like
this when I take this and do the inverse
other right what will be the problem
well you know how we look for the
vertical line test over here right when
you're thinking about inverses
everything swaps vertical isn't vertical
anymore it's now going to be horizontal
right if you swap X and y this vertical
line becomes horizontal so if I put a
horizontal line against this right have
a look
is there a place where it fails and the
answer is yes like anywhere up in here
you're in trouble right so if I swap
this thing around you will not get a
function because this part here once I
reflected over you fail the vertical
line test
does that make sense so I need to I need
to restrict the domain so if for example
let's call this let's just give it a
value let's call that negative one right
there and let's call this I don't know
that looks like 3/4 or something like
that okay I could take sections of this
can someone give me an example of a
restricted domain which if I took the
other side if I took the inverse it
would give me a function someone give me
an example where you think you're Essen
zero to where here's a zero - where - -
to the left of the right think right
come back over here look at this
original guy right I said okay to the
right is okay to the left is okay it's
this point where it turns that it's the
problem right so for example let's just
hide this will do fine it'll can be one
to one right see that section there if
you did the reflection that part would
be okay right it would it fails sorry it
passes the horizontal line test so when
you flip it over
it'll pass the vertical line test right
so this parts okay how would you state
that inequality that domain yeah X is
less than negative one or equal to it's
fine right but that's not the only
section that works right I need I need
another thing to hold off sorry yeah so
if I take this section here
see that's what there you see this
little section here is one to one right
so if you did that reflection it's gonna
be fine right there's one last section
can you see it can you tell me what it
is
now that I've like ruined what I've
written on the board by yeah yeah over
here right this part here
looks just like the part that we
restricted for the x squared graph right
so you can actually pick any of these
bits and you'll get an inverse function
out of it does that make sense so I'm
gonna write those answers for you just
so you know right X is less than
negative 1 that would give me any invest
funds between negative 1 & 3 over 4 that
would give me an inverse function or to
the right of 3 over 4 that would also
give me an inverse function
second would you write this one over
here
you know you're right you mean like an
interval notation you could I mean
exactly the same as this would be to
write that X belongs to 3/4 all the way
to infinity you could write it like that
if you want but they're exactly the same
thing
okay all right so in question seven
eight nine and ten they're going to ask
you about this right they're gonna ask
about well tell me about this mutual
investing can you show that this really
is the inverse by putting one into the
other it's a way of testing if someone
gives you two functions you can find out
whether it's the inverse or not by
putting one inside the other or vice
versa